this Little Rock has come from the
bottom of the Pacific Ocean some 14,000
ft down now it may look like a lump of
coal but it's actually dense with Cobalt
nickel manganese and copper some of the
key minerals in EV batteries the fact
that the company has been to the bottom
of the ocean and brought this to the
surface shows just how far we're now
willing to go in the hunt for the
minerals that will power our electric
vehicles see as demand for electric
vehicles increases the need for their
critical minerals is set to explode and
dramatically outpace Supply that's push
some startups to Pioneer new techniques
that could fundamentally reshape how we
find and extract the minerals for our
batteries so what do the frontiers of EV
battery mineral mining look
like let's start with this rock it's a
test sample that comes from here a huge
area 1,000 Mi off the coast of Mexico
called The Clarion clipon Zone and down
there our Rock isn't exactly a rare find
there are thousands of these potato siiz
nodules holding another one of them is
the metals Company CEO Gerard Baron
we're very fortunate that our nodules
literally lay on the ocean floor a
little bit like golf balls on a driving
range we don't have to go and dig or
drill or tunnel to find them they
literally laying there waiting for us to
pick them up the company's plan is to
send down robots like this to collect
the nodules and bring them up to the
surface for processing now while
companies have wanted to mine these
fields for decades a combination of
technological limitations and Regulatory
hurdles have prevented anyone from EXP
exp in the resource but that could all
change if and when the un's
international seabed Authority finalizes
its regulations on seabed mining so far
the governing body has given out 22
licenses to contractors to explore the
ocean floor but not to mine it it's a
bit of a land grab and I think as we
move closer to the final mining code
being adopted which we expect no later
than
2025 countries are Awakening to the fact
that this is an enormous economic
and National Security opportunity but as
with most mining deep sea mining isn't
without its controversy especially as
thousands of new species have been
discovered down there some groups have
called for an outright ban of the
practice meanwhile countries like Canada
and companies like BMW and Volvo have
asked for Progress to be paused until
protection of the Marine habitat can be
guaranteed the metals company says that
its operation will have the lightest
impact on the Marine ecosystem some
people want to move forward in a very
precautionary uh manner as do we that's
why we've spent now more than $400
million to fully understand those
impacts now while our ocean floor
minerals have been known about for
decades finding new deposits to mine can
be challenging and time consuming it
usually involves setting off seismic
charges or taking core samples and then
spending weeks analyzing that data but
startup Fleet space says that its
satellite Network could change that we
do an ultrasound for Mother Earth we
can't wait 15 years to find each new
deposit um as has been the case in
mining before the company deploys a grid
of ambient noise tomography sensors in
the ground that pick up natural micro
vibrations they listen to the ambient
rumbling of the earth and generate a
three-dimensional image of the
subsurface down to about 2.5 km the data
from Those sensors is then collected in
real time by a network of satellites
which send it off for instant processing
Fleet space says that this gives its
customers who includes the likes of
mining giant Rio Tinto the ability to
know what might lie beneath them within
days as opposed to months the company
told me that usually it can take around
600,000 Metter of drilling to find a new
deposit no one really wants to do that
and governments don't want to allow
people to just drill at random until
they hit things either we don't want to
turn the world into swiss cheese looking
for the metals that are going to sustain
our energy transition but there's one
potential source for these minerals that
doesn't involve going to the bottom of
the ocean or drilling lots of holes it
involves utilizing a resource SCE that
is right in front of you right now
recycling old batteries according to
analysts there's already around 650,000
tons of battery minerals in the us alone
in cars phones laptops and other
industrial sources and startup Redwood
materials formed in 2017 by former Tesla
CTO JB strable has the ambition of
recovering the minerals stored in those
items when they reach the end of their
life turning them back into battery
materials the company says they do this
by discharging the batteries and
dismantling them into their individual
components those components are then
shredded and turned into something
called Black Mass which goes through a
hydr metallurgic process to isolate the
critical minerals Redwood says this will
enable it to extract 30% of the lithium
and nickel and 100% of the Cobalt needed
to make a cathode the problem is while
there's set to be lots more EVS on the
market over the coming decade it will be
several more years before the batteries
in today's EVS reach the end of their
useful life and need to be recycled so
right now the company is mainly
recycling batteries from portable
electronic devices as well as
manufacturing scrap the waste product
that's created when making batteries
that's still enough for the company to
get through 40,000 metric tons of
recyclable material a year though it has
Ambitions to create enough anode and
cathode materials for 5 million electric
vehicles by 2030 now these companies may
be taking different approaches but they
have something in common they're all
betting on a future where these minerals
are val valuable and needed and their
plans have come to fruition but right
now the price of some of these raw
materials has been falling as demand for
EVS soften slightly and the more
minerals like this that are discovered
and mined the cheaper they could become
as they go from being something really
rare and precious to well pretty
common